herzlich willkommen zu meinem heutigen
video ich bin ja heute die ich alleine
ich bin zusammen mit sixt
wir haben kein video mehr zusammen macht
seitdem wir das video gemacht haben wir
uns getrennt haben hey was geht aber die
haben
ob es dort nicht wir mögen uns immer
noch sehr gerne videos auch gesagt haben
ein video das oft mit strafen wie
sonstwas und wir dachten uns deshalb
brauchen wir uns heute mal zusammen ein
haus das haus hinein spaß wir spielen
ist viel what's the box waffen es in der
box ja noch ein paar sachen mitgebracht
ich habe ein paar sachen mitgebracht die
werden wir abwechselnd hier rein legen
und dann denken die unsere herrliche so
rahn und führe was könnte es sein
zweites feuer sind das zwei kreise und
dann schauen wir noch unser vor ich bin
im kommunion style hier am start und
jana ist im handy alles wächst das spiel
trotzdem schrift
dann wird es auch so wird sich die haare
lassen manchen stellen wird
[Musik]
bitteres teil 4
okay du hast verloren und fängst an zu
wachsen gegenstand seien aber man es
machen bis zum kommunion zeitweilig
heute 19 toni collette bekommen habe
dass die leute abgegeben habe und erst
richtig auf dementsprechend anziehen ist
es irgendwas gefährlichen gegenstand ist
relativ leicht man kann hier irgendwie
sowas drücken ich habe ehrlich gesagt
jetzt so oft im ersten 1 und überhaupt
keine idee glauben man kann das hier
auseinander ziehen und ohne dazu bringen
kann ich sagen dass ein terrorist
das war aber echt schwer zu erkennen
weil ich habe in der regel ist auch zu
dingen aber im auge behalte ich mache
jetzt einfach dran war
mal sehen was könnte das sein
fühlt sich komisch an ich hab den
fingerspitzen berührt foto von dir sehr
viele fotos verwenden ok ich hab' ich
glaube es ist deine große franzosen
seiten müsse rechtlich seine schwarz dpa
berlin
aber muss man also auf die seite dann
passiert ist
oder hast du bei mir jedenfalls gespannt
darauf kommt ab wie die wilde fahrt
kommen lassen mussten
so was hatten wir noch nie in seiner
hand wieso kommen wurde rauch sichtbar
sind oben eigentlich immer mit den füßen
den media sagt oder lassen den an sehr
schwer es ist apple war verdeckt aber
das werde ich natürlich jetzt nicht ich
habe 35 richtig gespannt
es ist winter
da haben wir gehen nicht mal zu fühlen
richtig an
es geht eher um die form kann es auch
packen ist ja was verpackt also kannst
auch auspacken
[Musik]
das ist doch wer glaubt dass selbst der
türen rennt also ist eine sache die
blumen mehr benutzt ich habe nicht das
ziel ist jeweils ein leben in der hand
hat das was mit menstruation zu tun die
menschen reaktionen nicht mehr kommt ich
bin so läuft weiß nicht was das dritte
ich glaube ich nicht aufgeben ich weiß
nicht was es ist ich zeigt die top leute
dabei haben aber jetzt lasse ich würde
die nächste sache augen vielleicht
dauert diesmal weniger als eine
millisekunde bisher erkennt was es ist
es liegt drin britta walburg sieht man
diese zahlen bisher stets unentschieden
ist auch im vergleich gut da hast du
noch mal sagen für mich über bronze ok
mal gucken was die ästhetik meiner die
anerkannt
ich mache hier hätten der linken wollte
ancelotti im konzern als kanal
breitmachte mal ein auge zu ich habe
noch was hab ich wieder was schweres
natürlich okay
doch die sache die schon hatte ok
losgeht wenn daisy kopf ständig als in
dieser sache jetzt einen kanal ja es ist
tatsächlich sehr gut gespielt haben ich
würde sagen du bist sie sehen hier
siegerin eines vergleichbar
wer ist besser salas oder jana stimmt
hier ab